this is a uh
a clip from support court is what it
says here in the corner
which i don't know it's a hollywood tv
show obviously so some of this is going
to be manufactured but
i've heard versions of this over the
years from guys that i've had one-on-one
consults with i've had guys call in
and if you've watched the series long
enough you've seen me talk to other guys
that um have uh shared their experiences
that a guy on a couple months ago his
wife tried to poison him during the
divorce but um
let's hear what this fine lady has to
say here let's go
see if we can put it up on the full
screen here for you to get a better view
here we go kid so your stay-at-home mom
mm-hmm
and she's 11. he yeah he is 11.
he goes to school he does so what do you
do during the day
nothing you don't want to work no
no so you're just living off of his
child support
i am and we live with our mother now
child support is designed to support the
child okay that's why it's called
child support in my book
in the chapter about why smart men don't
marry unplugged alpha
on amazon i outlined a story a friend of
mine
who calculated while he was married he
was paying
roughly about 550 a month i think it was
to take care of the necessities for the
child you know
toiletries diapers baby food formula all
that kind of stuff
when you split up when you plug in your
income
into the child support tables which
again is supposed to be for
child support worked out to close to 4
500 bucks
so more often than not child support
doesn't go to care for the child when
the child's not in your care
it first goes to the mother she scrapes
off what she needs and then the leftover
goes to the child
that's the way family law works let's
carry on here you're proud of that
well we were living with him and i was a
stay-at-home mom he made the income
okay but i mean but you can work now
right i can but
so it's nobody but you can go get a job
right
i could but i'm not going to i want my
rent's free
my food is free i mean
my mom's the homeowner we don't have to
pay nothing okay
all right so she's a stay-at-home mom or
she was a stay-at-home mom
to one child who's 11 and now in school
and she's in family court
trying to get money out of the out of
the old man head of the dad
again this is just one example
you